hey was geht ab und herzlich willkommen
bei einem neuen blog ich bin hier im
urlaub auf formentera ich weiß nicht ob
ihr das kennt ist neben pizza spanische
insel balearen und ich bin jetzt schon
das zwanzigste mal habe allerdings noch
wie ein blog gemacht so wirklich vor
lisa wunderschöne insel
deswegen machen wir das heute das ist
hier unser gefährt sondern roller
eigentlich wollten wir ein quad aber ist
nicht mehr so wirklich erlaubt hier
zeigt euch einfach mal die heftigen
strände hier und wünsche euch ganz viel
spaß mit diesem video es auch noch sagen
[Musik]
so leute wir sind jetzt hier am strand
ich war hier schon länger nicht mehr auf
jeden fall ist es fast an der küste also
an dem nördlichsten punkt glaube ich
hier ist es heute irgendwie extrem
windig aber das coole man hat hier
einmal die eine seite und die anderen
seite und wenn man sich das wasser mal
anschaut
es fällt schon extrem geil wir liegen
auch immer ziemlich verbote und so diese
ganzen fußballer die machen jetzt
ziemlich oft urlaub wenn sie halt mal
wieder eine saison scheiße gespielt
haben aber trotzdem 20 millionen im jahr
verdienen
auf jeden fall würde ich sagen ich gehe
jetzt erst mal schwimmen ich habe einen
körper dabei auch noch eine drohne
das ding ist nur es ist halt wie gesagt
ziemlich windig deswegen würde ich den
nicht unbedingt steigen lassen
zumindest jetzt noch nicht heute abend
wird es vielleicht ein bisschen wünschte
also leute ich würde sagen ich gehe
jetzt erst mal schwimmen
[Musik]
leute ich hab kein klarer wie mich
verstehen könnt auf jeden fall ist es
hier nicht so wenig wie ein land warum
auch immer
das wasser ist wirklich glaube ich das
heftigste was man so in europa finden
kann
und wahrlich nicht
geil freut mich
neulich war hier gerade im wasser und
sehen neben mir so eine feuerquelle und
denke mir so geil lange nicht mehr
gesehen
und plötzlich gucke ich um mich und
alles voll dann bin ich erst mal raus
gesprintet war
[Musik]
so leute werden jetzt schon halb sieben
oder so und fahren jetzt wieder zurück
ich habe auch genug sonne für heute
schaut euch gern noch mal diese bucht an
wir lagen irgendwo ganz hinten
ist ein bisschen schwer gerade war ich
ziemlich viel schleppen muss ich habe
aber auf jeden fall richtig cool auch
noch gemacht mit der drohne und bin froh
wenn ich jetzt gleich duschen kann weil
ich bin voll mit sand so jetzt müssen
wir unseren roller finden
nachdem scheiße die kamera ist ganz
schön dreckig so leute wir sind jetzt
schon wieder zurück gehen jetzt was
essen habe geduscht
ich bin ein echter braun geworden auch
im gesicht und habe hier den heftigen
sonnenbrand ich bin brauner aber sowas
wie unsere beine und auf jeden fall gibt
es hier ziemlich viele coole restaurants
die sind so am strand entlang ja wir
haben jetzt mittlerweile ich mein handy
vergessen wie spät ist es ja
mittlerweile 9 uhr und hatten einen sehr
aufregenden tag ich will euch jetzt gar
nicht langweilen mit meinem lover
deswegen es später
[Musik]
so leute wir sehen jetzt fertig mit
essen ist auch schon 24 uhr wird jetzt
froh dass ich schlafen kann und hier ist
perfekte belichtung um diesen
wunderschönen blog zu werden ich hoffe
es hat euch gefallen ich habe keine
ahnung wie lange das wird und ob es
überhaupt sinn macht das ganze zusammen
zu karten weil es ziemlich ein wenig
mich nur ich muss schauen inwiefern ich
die aufnahmen für dieses video benutzen
kann worte hier ist oder für ein anderes
video das auf unsere reise kanal online
kommt ganz oben in der beschreibung
verlinkt auf jeden fall abonnieren da
gibt es ein cooles video zu dieser
schöne insel hier aber nicht vergessen
wir sehen uns mittwoch wieder montag
meine ich bin voll mit den tagen
auseinander haut rein
[Musik]